darüber wollen wir mit einem
sicherheitsexperten sprechen mit carlo
masala professor für internationale
politik an der universität der
bundeswehr in münchen und auch hier im
heutigen land inzwischen ein vertrautes
gesicht guten amt der professor
salamanca zu den merkwürdigen
nebenwirkungen eines solchen krieges
gehört ja dass man sich auch als
militärischer laie wie es die meisten
unserer zuschauer sind plötzlich mit
waffensystemen und solchen fragen
beschäftigt das war es jetzt unter
anderem deutschland liefert zum beispiel
solche flugabwehrraketen bringt das
jetzt eigentlich den ukrainern also der
armee dort überhaupt noch was oder ist
das eher symbolisch
nein also das was jetzt geliefert wird
seit letzter woche ist nicht symbolisch
sondern hat durchaus einen realen
militärischen wert also die sie da zum
beispiel kann durchaus dazu beitragen
die russische luftüberlegenheit jetzt
nicht zu brechen aber es schwieriger zu
machen so russische flugzeuge sozusagen
ihre angriffe zu fliegen und alles was
boden boden raketen sind hilft den
ukrainern den vormarsch russischer
verwende zumindest zu verzögern oder gar
in teilen zu stoppen also von daher es
gibt einen militärischen mehr wert aber
wir dürfen uns keine illusionen hingeben
der wird nicht dazu führen dass da jetzt
sozusagen das ganze spielt sich umdreht
und ihm keine armee plötzlich in die
offensive gehen kann und den russen
wirklich massive verluste zufügen da
kriegen sie jetzt eher pessimistisch
also es wird ja auch zum beispiel
darüber diskutiert warum die russen in
am boden zu mindestens zum teil mit sehr
alten panzern und sehr sehr jungen
soldaten unterwegs sind die zum teil
plündern weil sie nicht mehr genug zu
essen haben also scheint bei der
nachschub nicht so funktionieren kann es
nicht auch sein dass die russische armee
vielleicht gar nicht so gut ausgerüstet
ist wie sie mal behauptet hat dass da
viel durch korruption abgeflossen ist
ich weiß nicht ob es durch korruption
abgeschlossen ist aber was wir
feststellen ist sozusagen das ganze
hightech gerät was uns die russen seit
2008 immer medial präsentiert haben in
der ukraine nicht vorzufinden ist und
wir müssen uns ganz einfach eingestehen
dass das bild das wir über die russische
armee hatten seit 2008 hat er gesagt dem
beginn der großen militärreform sehr
dadurch beeinflusst war was die russen
uns glauben lassen wollten jetzt sehen
wir in der ukraine dass die russen in
ihrer operationsführung viele sachen die
eigentlich basic sind einfach nicht
beachten also eine grottenschlechte
logik sieg die dazu führt dass sozusagen
kein diesel da ist fanta liegen bleiben
keine feldküchen da sind soldaten nach
34 tagen einfach nichts mehr zu essen
haben und das sind kapitale fehler
anfängerfehler in dem sinne wie wir den
russen eigentlich so nicht zugetraut
haben und jetzt feststellen so zu sagen
sie sind in ihrer operationsführung
nicht viel weiter und moderner geworden
bleibt noch die frage was jetzt
eigentlich das militärische ziel ist
also in tschetschenien krieg putin
damals zum beispiel die einzige große
stadt in dem land grosny in schutt und
asche gelegt da stand ja kein stein mehr
auf dem anderen aber die ukraine ist ja
nicht stehen da sind ganz viele städte
will er die alle jetzt dann verwüsten
weil er anders nicht gewinnen kann was
glauben sie
ich glaube nicht dass wir die alle
vergessen will aber sozusagen wir sehen
an vielen städten sozusagen das jetzt
rein geschossen wird es hat noch nicht
die qualität wie sozusagen die
operationsführung in grosny oder was die
russen zusammen mit denen mit den syrern
in aleppo gemacht haben aber der krieg
wird härter der krieg wird brutaler und
es geht um die strategisch wichtigen
städte die jetzt alle unter beschuss
sind und hier muss man ganz einfach
sagen
ist die russische operationsführung
jetzt auch mehr in richtung rote lied
und gewalt gegenüber zivilisten
übergegangen und das werden wir
sicherlich in den nächsten tagen noch
wie viel stärker erleben
dann sind wir jetzt ja quasi in
irgendeiner form er auch militärisch
beteiligt wenn wir waffen liefern meinen
sie dass die russen das als provokation
empfinden es gab der diese etwas
eigenartige verletzung des luftraums
über schweden das sah aus wie achtung
passt bloß auf was ihr tut oder wie
interpretieren sie das
die verletzung des luftraums über
schweden glaube steht im zusammenhang
mit der debatte in schweden und auch in
finnland über
einen nato beitritt und darauf hat ja
sozusagen den finnen und den späten
briefe geschrieben in denen er sozusagen
harte sicherheitsgarantien verlangt mit
blick auf russland also ich glaube das
hat nichts mit diesen waffenlieferungen
jetzt erst mal von unserer seite zu tun
und man muss einfach sagen waffen dürfen
geliefert werden dass die russen und
jetzt möglicherweise auf der verbalen
ebene als eine indirekte kriegspartei
ansehen das haben wir nicht in der hand
weil die russen sozusagen sich ihre
narrativ selber bilden wie sie wollen
aber wenn man es rein völkerrechtlich
betrachtet dann sind wir nicht in
direkte konfliktpartei und von daher ist
die waffenlieferung eigentlich keine
gefahr für die bundesrepublik
deutschland ist professor carlo masala
ich danke für ihre expertise und das
gespräch
danke ihnen